the news is often determined to tell us
that we live in uniquely critical times
beset by political disasters and
afflicted by terrible crises and that
the demise of human civilization is
surely imminent we're encouraged by the
media to view the world and our own
lives in Bleak apocalyptic terms
oddly history can be powerfully
consoling at such moments not because it
tells us that our times are great but
precisely because it shows us how normal
large societal troubles actually are
the English 18th century historian
Edward Gibbon is particularly helpful
with this task of bringing us to a less
frightened perspective on what we Face
his massive elegantly written work the
history of the decline and fall of the
Roman Empire covers a thousand five
hundred years from the Pinnacle of Roman
power around the year 180 A.D through to
the collapse of the Western Empire to
the final fall of its last outpost the
city of Constantinople in 1453
Edward Gibbon started work on the series
of volumes around 1770 and completed the
final book on a summer's evening in 1787
while he was on holiday in Switzerland
the immense story that Gibbon tells us
moves from one disaster to another
Century after Century there are mad
despotic Emperors The Barbarians invade
again and again the plans for reform
fail the key institutions become corrupt
the government loses control of the army
there are plagues that last for decades
the Harvest decline there is insane
factionalism the economy collapses the
Roman Forum once the heart of the Empire
is abandoned and sheep graze among the
ruins only Constantinople holds out
getting weaker and weaker the vastly
prolonged decline ends with a fall of
that city where the people still call
themselves Roman to Muhammad II in the
middle of the 15th century and yet the
world did not end the main beneficiaries
of the demise of the last fragment of
the empire was the city-state of Venice
which became the most widely loved place
on Earth
and The Exodus of Scholars to the West
Was pivotal in the story of the
Renaissance and all the time in the
centuries of decline new forces were
developing in the background The Wild
People of the north who the Romans so
feared became eventually Danish interior
designers and German intellectuals and
Parisian socialites the picts and the
Scots who were seen as the least
civilized people on Earth by the Romans
would one day renew their Capital City
Edinburgh as an architectural homage to
Roman culture
the disasters are always happening on
the surface they're what we hear about
the gradual process of renewal and
elevation so often escapes are noticed
at the time
it's nice and good to read Edward Gibbon
late at night at the end of another day
when the news seems unbearably grim and
to skim through his Placid accounts of
yet another moment of apparent
catastrophe and think of him sitting
learnedly in his study in the 18th
century reflecting on disaster and yet
being himself the obvious Heir with his
classical prose his quiet dignity and
his sense of balance of the very Roman
Empire he thought he was lamenting